Donald Trump will be arrested tomorrow
he will surrender in New York City he
will appear in court presumably to enter
a plea of not guilty at which point he
is expected to leave New York City fly
back to Florida and hold what will
certainly be an unhinged press
conference at Mar-A-Lago shortly after 8
PM eastern time we're going to be
covering all of it live we will be live
tomorrow with the arraignment and we
will be live tomorrow with the press
conference that is essentially all I can
tell you at this time because there are
so many unknowns at this point one of
those unknowns is whether the
arraignment will be televised I'm going
to separate that question out just for a
moment because it's really its own
question and we will talk a little bit
about what is to be expected tomorrow
the latest news is that Trump will fly
from Florida to New York today Monday
and even though the arraignment is
scheduled for 2 15 tomorrow there are
reports that Trump will be at the
courthouse early in the morning why
isn't exactly clear certainly
fingerprints potentially a mug shot not
expected to be handcuffed based on
everything we know right now but that
doesn't take that long is it because of
security considerations well maybe
there's a numerous reports that New York
plans to close key streets for Trump's
arraignment Patricia Hurtado from
Bloomberg news reporting that and that
the entire area surrounding the
Manhattan courthouse is going to be
closed down to vehicle traffic it is
also known that there are
uh tunnels and different ways to get to
the main courthouse building from
surrounding buildings and for security
reasons presumably Donald Trump may be
brought in through some kind of
Securities path it's not exactly
completely clear we continue to learn
more about what are the charges
initially we didn't know then we knew
that the number was over 30. more
recently it's it's sort of uh focused in
on the number 34 questions about is it
all misdemeanors the latest report from
CBS news is that there are felony
charges here so not only charges against
Trump not only nearly three dozen
charges against Trump in this one of
three or four major criminal
investigations but felony charges as
well at least one of them CBS news
reporting former president Donald Trump
faces a felony charge A source told CBS
News Saturday
a person familiar with the matter said
to CBS News Trump is being charged with
falsifying business records in the first
degree which is a felony in New York
state now immediately the Law and Order
people coming out and saying it
shouldn't be a felony this is part of
the problem screw that well
if you're for Law and Order right now
that's a felony and if you are not above
the law if we have Justice then everyone
regardless of their position job wealth
or situation of power would be subject
to that law but how quickly the Law and
Order people change their tune when it
is all of a sudden inconvenient there
were concerns about violent protests as
a result of trumpists showing up here or
there now I don't believe we are yet out
of the woods because there is a protest
planned tomorrow at noon in New York
City involving repugnant and radical
reactionary Republican congresswoman
Marjorie Taylor green we will talk about
that separately but the good news so far
is that the protests we've seen at Trump
Tower in New York City and at Mar-A-Lago
have been pathetic
um a report from Bloomberg news is that
at Mar-A-Lago few show up to protest
Trump's indictment they there were a
dozen maybe two dozen people quite
pathetic and honestly I'm glad
I'm glad I don't want there to be
violence and there was some video from
New York City where I think there was
one pro tour one it's not even a protest
it's sort of like a show of support at
uh Trump Tower where there were one or
two people not one or two dozen one or
two people which is absolutely hilarious
now many of you have started to write to
me and said David you know we know
you're going to be away in a little bit
are you what's the timeline of this
Trump thing are you going to be around
to cover it the expectation
is that number one these things don't
move that quickly and number two you
always want to delay delay delay as much
as you can there's an interesting
article called Donald Trump's
time-tested legal strategy attack and
delay this article from dny uz says
these two tactics have been at the
center of Donald Trump's favorite
strategy in court cases for much of his
adult life and will likely be the former
president's approach to fighting the
criminal charges now leveled against him
you want to delay as much as possible
and many attorneys will tell you there
are a whole bunch of reasons for this
you can delay with the hopes that those
in charge of Prosecuting the case get
frustrated change jobs whatever you can
delay and delay and delay with the hopes
that Witnesses forget their testimony or
they die or whatever the case may be it
is often said by attorneys in many
different areas of criminal law
the longer you can delay actually
adjudicating a case the better and so
none of listen the fact that I'll be
away next week shouldn't at all Impact
my ability to cover this because we
could be talking about months if not if
not years potentially here and that is
certainly to be expected I am not aware
in terms of the defense that this is all
political that this is all a Witch Hunt
that these are merely political
decisions rather than legal decisions
this is one of the main defenses we've
heard from people around Donald Trump I
can't think of anyone that has used the
demand of political investigations more
than Donald Trump when Trump and and his
political allies say investigate Hillary
lock up Hillary lock up Hunter charge
Joe Biden etc etc absent any reason to
do so it is they who have demanded the
political prosecution of their opponents
and Trump is at the top of that so every
time we hear this is all Alvin Bragg's
Soros politics this that the other thing
don't let your eye come away from the
ball
and the ball is all along Trump has been
at the top of the list of those who
demand the political prosecution of his
opponents let's now talk about the
potential gag order and the potential
for Donald Trump to be re-arrested one
of our continued sponsors is ground news
and app and website that Aggregates
local and international news sources to
show you how breaking news is being
reported around the world it has become
a go-to resource for me right now I'm
looking at a story about residents in
Ohio reporting medical symptoms after
the train derailment ground news shows
the headline from The Washington Post
owned by Jeff Bezos says East Palestine
residents should look to agent orange
victims the headline from The Epic Times
a radical right-wing Outlet says Federal
officials enter 500 East Palestine homes
after toxic train crash I also like that
you can sort things by factuality
location and bias check out ground news
for free at Ground dot News slash Pacman
if you find ground news as useful as I
do subscribe for unlimited access the
link is down below